things are revealed and now I know raka
my shirt then negan Sluggers
you've all got that lootcrate to sweet
surfer today just season seven of The
Walking Dead has premiered whoo negan
killed with the bat has been revealed up
you don't want that just boiled for ya
this is a spoiler warning you need to go
in fact if you haven't seen it yet what
are you doing on the internet you should
not be here right spoiler warning done
if anything spoiled is now your fault
and bless all you wonderful Twitter
followers who are like you need to video
help us through this [ __ ] thus Here I am
I wasn't gonna do a video about it then
I decided to okay so The Walking Dead
Season seven started out Rick had blood
across his face I was like okay so the
deed is done and we know Rick's alive so
he didn't die then after that Rick said
he's gonna kill [ __ ] I'm gonna kill
you go ultimately the point of the
episode is negan takes Rick into the RV
and drives him around and ultimately
proceeds to whip him into shape and
break him for the next hour and he does
and that's pretty much the disturbing
thing about the episode granted this
episode had a lot stacking on Matt it
was like a stack of hellish ass pancakes
you don't want to eat it so among the
road trip the reveal is who dies and it
shows eenie meenie miney mo thing and
then boom stops on Abraham I was like
yep figured Abraham was one of my picks
for who negan killed
sure enough waxham is like talking like
[ __ ] and Abraham goes eat my nuts and
then negan proceeded to just turn his
head into soup which is great for
Abraham because his last words on earth
are eat my nuts I would love to be so
lucky in fact every night when I go to
bed I'm going to say aloud someone's
there or not
eat my nuts so if I ever die in the
night for some odd reason you all know
and you can advocate and fight for the
fact that eat my nuts were my last words
please put it on a tombstone so Abraham
is now dead they're on a road trip and
then it starts flashing back to what
happened after Abraham died the Florida
negan took Rick Abraham is dead
everyone's in shock and Daryl stands up
and slugs negan one of the guys has
across was like oh let me do it and he
goes like not you don't kill him he's
got Moxie kid he's got moxie and I was
sitting there like alright negan you
said if that ever happened again you
would shut that [ __ ] down no exceptions
what's the point of killing Abraham to
make a point and prove how powerful and
tough you are and man of your word then
he's gonna slug even nothing's going to
happen
[ __ ] cuz they're not gonna kill
to people huh and then he addresses he's
like I said if that ever happened again
I would shut that [ __ ] down no
exceptions you're like alright I shut
that [ __ ] down no exceptions means what
I think it means at this point someone
else is dying
two people [ __ ] no you're not gonna do
that [ __ ] I that that's dick sure enough
right there you see who's framed up he's
like so back to it you're like oh my god
they're gonna kill Glenn and he proceeds
to beat Glenn's head with that bat it's
[ __ ] up too I'm not gonna lie I saw
some articles like the violence go too
far it's nothing we really we've seen
some heinous [ __ ] in the walking dead
before the fact it happened to people we
know and love that's the [ __ ] part
that's the part we don't like it's the
powerlessness at the show vicariously
forces on our shoulders people don't
like powerlessness so we don't like that
yeah he's like heads cracked and caved
in his eyeballs bugging out who's trying
to say something to Maggie I think he
says Maggie I'll find you then negan
proceeds to turn his head to paste to
Abraham and Glenn they're both dead
which if you see how it's laid out I
like okay we couldn't just kill Glenn
because that's who died in the comic
book so it's a little too obvious so
they have to throw something at us to
throw us off center like oh is Abraham
not Glenn Glenn is safe no Glenn's not
safe my jaw actually hit the floor when
I saw her because I just didn't expect
that I didn't expect to people granted
to the show it got me however part of
the effectiveness of killing off a
character is having it happen and having
people not go through it before there
were a number of us myself included who
were convinced that Glenn died when he
fell in front of the walkers you
remember the dumpster thing and that
whole psyche out fact it was a psych-out
doesn't change the fact that there were
people who were like I'm dealing with
the fact I'm going through all the
stages of acceptance in the fact that
Glenn died and so it was like yep Glenn
died doesn't reveal is that oh he didn't
die and so Glenn's alive and he's with
us but now that it happened a second
time clearly officially Glenn is gone I
just can't help but think that it would
have been more effective had some of us
not had to deal with the fact that Glenn
had already died before for people who
were never fooled about the whole Glenn
thing in the dumpster a good job
fantastic for the rest of you or the
rest of us a loss of Glenn now is
something that we have
felt before and the death of a character
is effective because you feel that
impact once and for the last time when
you feel it twice it's just less
effective and it also doesn't change the
fact that negan clearly proved who's in
charge Rick is hanging from a walker at
a point I was like he might die I
wouldn't put it past him to kill three
people now then when he has him in front
of Carl he straps Carl's arm off he just
gives him his hatchet he's like cut
Carl's arm off I just can't deny the
fact that at a point when you have Rick
hanging from a walker and I feel like in
my head like he might die we have Carl's
arm and you're like that might get
sliced off the show has effectively at
least this episode made me feel like
anything was possible for anybody and
that's rare in a show and Rick has now
been whipped into shape Rick knows who's
in charge Rick is not in charge
negan is yeah [ __ ] like this guy
looked at me wrong I don't like the way
it looks at me I'd love to torture him
for an entire season cut his dick off
and named him reek but I just don't have
that time so I have to do it in 1/10 the
time so that was pretty much the gist of
the episode the entire episode was negan
establishing who is boss Abraham died
wasn't so surprised
Glen died was very surprised if Glen had
just died I'd have been surprised enough
the fact they killed two people we were
all speculating on one no one got it
right because no one was like does
clearly - we didn't know I feel I felt
dirty after this episode and I hated it
like one of those things where you start
thinking like am I even gonna watch the
show again [ __ ] it then you realize it's
the powerlessness that you feel in a
shitty ass situation like that and he's
got it I gotta give the show props
there's not another show on TV that
makes me feel how the Walking Dead makes
me feel it's like I'm their puppet on
their strings he really is a dick I mean
I'm not like the bodies are still there
and he takes Rick for a drive for about
an hour and everyone feels like a family
and their dead bodies are just there and
that's just really heinous [ __ ] he's a
dick but I am looking forward to this
season because I want to see him die
horribly and Jeffrey Dean Morgan does a
good job because that's just good
casting we're gonna get through this
but I do need a hug all right guys so
the Walking Dead Season 7 premiere what
did you think about it what do you think
about who negan picked to die and the
whole I hates two people Glen included
whatever you think about that comment
below let me know and as always if you
liked what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]